[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american prison comedy
film called big stan
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
stan minton is a real estate agent
living in la who has everything he wants
in life he is filthy rich and has a
beautiful wife mindy who he cheats on i
mean loves stan has a unique way of
selling properties to his clients he
usually cheats them out of a small
amount which has over the years grown
large hence one day he is arrested for
first degree fraud he is found guilty
and is told that he will get a sentence
of at least three years in prison
desperate to find a way out he asks his
lawyer to bribe the judge the lawyer
does as told but the conviction is
absolute by faking a charity event he
only manages to get stan's six months
free time before being imprisoned after
the hearing the lawyer suggests stan
take a long trip to brazil and never
return but he cannot do so because all
of his assets have been frozen stan has
no choice but to live the next few
months in fear of what is about to come
starting that day he does everything
quicker because of the limited time one
evening he is on a date with mindy who
wants to have a kid so she won't be
alone when he is gone stan thinks the
idea is absurd because they will have to
give up the kid for adoption when he
returns he dreads the idea of having
children which creates a rift in his
relationship with his wife mindy storms
off after his comment while stan drives
to a bar at random while drinking he
notices a man beside him with a tattoo
about going to prison he asks the guy
for tips on prison life and offers him a
hundred bucks to talk the man starts by
saying that the prison guards do not
care about the inmates and their fights
the prisoners could kill each other but
as long as they don't escape they let
you do anything he also adds that stan
looks like someone who would most
definitely be sexually violated by the
inmates stan realizes that all the
rumors about men turning gay in prison
are true he is weak and submissive which
makes him the perfect target when the
man suggests he gets several tattoos to
avoid being targeted stan shows him a
tattoo of his mother on his arm which
clearly won't work the man then advises
him to join one of the groups in the
prison the groups are mostly divided
into nazis racists mexican men and
african-american men but since stan
doesn't fit into any of those categories
his last resort is to just kill someone
so the inmates would be scared of him
the following morning he wakes up with a
hangover and thinks that he was just
dreaming he is distressed when mindy
tells him he's still going to prison to
uplift him she mentions his special
quality is that he always finds a way
this encourages stan and he makes it his
mission to become an alpha in the next
six months effective immediately he
exercises every day and gets a tattoo on
his behind to make it less attractive he
also joins a karate class but is bored
when asked to learn the basics he
challenges the teacher and gets in a
fight with one of the kids which results
in him being thrown out of the
establishment this is when he meets an
old man named the master he impresses
stan by breaking a hole in the wall with
no effort he is stan's only hope to
learn self-defense before going to
prison hence he brings the old man home
to train with him the master starts
living with them much to mindy's
annoyance on his first day of training
stan is woken up at five in the morning
by blood from an animal liver pouring on
his face then the master makes mindy
blend ox pancreas and horse tongues to
make a smoothie for her husband his
methods of training are different and
over the top some days he hits stan with
a flaming stick while other days he
hangs him by his skin to test his
endurance he also feeds stan a variety
of weird food like scorpions and snakes
mindy who is tired of the master smoking
all around the house asks her husband to
get rid of him that night stan pretends
that they are being robbed and makes
mindy think she is about to be sexually
assaulted it turns out that he is doing
this to make her feel what he is feeling
when mindy stops panicking she packs her
luggage and leaves claiming that she
doesn't want to be with him anymore and
who can blame her the master is
delighted that she left because with
only men in the house the training can
get tougher for the next five months
stan works hard without resting by the
end of it he manages to take the master
by surprise in combat for his last test
he goes to fight the karate teacher who
once threw him out of his class stan
defeats the man easily and completes his
training he is finally ready to defend
himself when he needs to the master and
the lawyer drop him off at the court
mindy has still not talked to him but
she watches him secretly from inside her
car stan finally goes inside and is
transported to the prison on a bus
immediately a guy tries to touch him
inappropriately but stan teaches him a
lesson at the prison they are welcomed
by warden gask who kindly asks them to
not trouble the guards but other than
that they can do anything they please to
each other during the cavity check the
new inmates are asked to strip and bend
over the guards are horrified to see
stan's behind that he is modified to
make it look unpleasant following the
cavity check he goes to his cell and
meets his roommate larry to assert his
dominance he asks larry to take the
lower bonk later larry tells him about
the prison guards who have basically
formed a gang the first gang is a group
of black men the second one is a team of
mexican thugs the third one is nazis and
the fourth one is racists then there is
a group of scientists who are great at
killing people by talking too much
lastly he is introduced to the most
dangerous sexual predator of the block
big raymond raymond is terrorizing a new
inmate when stan approaches him and
challenges him in front of everyone they
get into a fight where stan uses
self-defense techniques taught by the
master to beat him easily impressed by
his skills the leader of the nazi group
patterson tries to invite him to their
team but stan just beats him up as well
then he is approached by the
african-american team who are furious
that he fought big raymond stan tries to
avoid the fight claiming that he is also
black however the leader orders his team
to attack and a fight breaks out the
guards enjoy the show while stan defeats
them efficiently after the commotion the
entire prison is afraid of stan people
make way for him everywhere he goes they
all establish him as the alpha of the
prison and call him big stan a young guy
named robbie who he saved from raymond
earlier comes to thank him but stan
dismisses him claiming that he didn't
fight those guys for anyone other than
himself later warden gask calls stan to
his office and reveals that he pushed
some buttons to get stan in this
specific prison it turns out that gask
is planning to take over the prison
property and build an estate since stan
is an experienced realtor he wants his
help to find out any flaw in the
documents relating to it in turn for his
help stan is offered to be freed after
only a year of imprisonment the idea
piques his interest and he agrees to
help he asks gask how he is going to get
rid of the prison but the warden wants
to keep that part a secret in the
meantime the groups of inmates have
joined hands to teach stan a lesson
while he is showering one day patterson
attacks him with a knife made out of a
melted toothbrush and a razor blade in
turn stan brings out his nunchaku made
of soap bars and a shoelace he easily
beats patterson up and sends him to the
hospital stan misses his wife
desperately and wants to meet her he
contacts his lawyer to see if she has
sent him the divorce papers to his
relief she hasn't yet after that he
begins to work on the wardens project he
is introduced to a vietnamese
mafia-turned politician dang who is
gask's partner on the project and is
helping him sabotage the prison stan
overhears them talking about their plan
to get rid of the prison from the
property he finds out that they are
about to make the inmates fight each
other so the guards shoot some of them
that way the board of governors will
have to consider closing the prison
altogether because it is not being
managed properly stan feels like it is
his responsibility to help the inmates
even though they want to kill him the
following day he arranges a meeting to
set some rules and boundaries in the
prison first he throws away all their
violent video games and movies because
they are a bad influence then he
declares sexual assault as a punishable
crime anyone who does it has to answer
to him directly when the men whine he
asks them to just be involved in
consensual sex instead the concept is
new to them but they agree to do it
anyway during the next lunch break
robbie and some men approach stan's
table and thank him for making the no
assault rules stan tries to pass it off
as him asserting dominance but robbie
knows that he cares about their
well-being at another table big raymond
and his new boyfriend can be seen
enjoying a meal together they are in a
happy relationship thanks to stan robbie
and his group along with big raymond and
his boyfriend joined stan's group after
that stan is given a letter addressed to
him by mindy he had written to her
apologizing for doing what he did and
now she wants to meet with him over the
next couple of days if anyone gets into
an argument they come to stand to solve
it eventually everyone starts liking
each other and living in harmony one day
mindy comes to visit stan and the two
make love at the same time gask is
informed about what stan has been up to
the man is furious at him for solving
the inmates conflicts stan is dragged
away in the middle of his special time
with mindy gask calls him out for trying
to sabotage his plan and threatens to
make dang kill him if he doesn't follow
their orders the following day stan
calls his lawyer to ask for his opinion
the lawyer suggests he do is told
because gask is a powerful man after the
call stan tells everyone that their
problem is not his responsibility and
they can go back to how they were before
he came to the prison soon the fights
start to break out again robbie
approaches stan in the cafeteria but he
throws the poor guy's plate to ask him
to go away even larry is disappointed in
him he tries to walk away but stan stops
him and asks him to stay away from the
metal fence at noon larry realizes that
stan is being forced into doing
something he doesn't want to do he tells
all the other inmates about this and
they start to plan something meanwhile
gask arranges a meeting between stan and
the parole board to discuss his early
release while he is in the meeting gask
shows the board of governors around the
prison he plans to execute the plan at
noon near the fence since most of the
inmates get into conflicts at noon he
wants to take the opportunity to kill
some of them while the board members
witness it stan pretends to be a
horrible person in front of the parole
board in order to get out of the room
and alert the others to not go near the
fence he is stopped by dang who reveals
that he has also been trained by the
master they get into an intense fight
initially dang is proven to be more
skilled but stan takes the lead and
knocks dang out by this time the inmates
have already gathered in the field with
weapons the guards get ready to shoot
them but to their surprise the inmates
perform a dance number to a mexican song
a frustrated gask snatches a gun and
fires randomly the board sees this and
is ready to take action against him
before going down gask wants to kill
stan but he is saved by mindy it is
revealed that she had been training with
the master for the past six months the
scene then cuts to three years later
stan has finally completed his prison
time and is returning home his fellow
inmates wish them goodbye and patterson
even gets a tattoo of his face on his
belly having a nazi tattoo your face on
their stomach talk about squad goals
mindy and the master come to pick him up
with his three-year-old daughter in tow
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching